شكرا لميسور اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
نستكمل واياكم هذه التغطيه المتواصله على
مدار الساعه والتي نخصصها لمتابعه ورصد
الاوضاع في السودان والاشتباكات المندلعه
هناك منذ ايام بين كل من الجيش والدعم
السريع تطورات اليوم هي التزام لا باس به
بالهدنه تستغلها دول لاجلاء دبلوماسيه
ومواطنيها من هناك فيما يشهد محيط قياده
الجيش بالخرطوم اشتباكات متقطعه بين طرفي
النزاع اما عن اعداد الضحايا فوصلت الى
420 قتيلا فيما تجاوز عدد الجرحى 4000 شخص
وفقا لارقام امميه كشفت عنها منظمه الصحه
العالميه
[موسيقى]
في اخر التطورات الميدانيه اعلن الجيش
السوداني عبر التلفزيون رسمي سيطره
الكامله على مدينه الاوبيض
اصبحت مدينه الاوبيض الان امنه سالمه
هانئه مطمئنه ندعو جميع المواطنين لفتح
الاسواق ومزاوله اعمالهم من صباح الغد
[تصفيق]
اصبحت المدينه امنه مطمئنه
كما مثل الجيش مشاهد لسيطره قوته على
معسكر للدعم السريع في ام درمان نتابع
[موسيقى]
رياض الان الاستاذ محمود السوداني اهلا بك
معنا محمود هل هناك اي مؤشرات على انه
الاتصالات الدائره حاليا يمكن ان تنتج
التزاما اكبر بالهدنه
الو نعم استاذ محمود انت على الهواء
مباشره
مرحبا اهلا وسهلا
طبعا يعني
الالتزام بالهدنه يعني لازم يكون في مراقب
دولية
يعني لو انت يعني جيت ضربت امثله في كل
الصراعات اللي حصلت في كل العالم لازم
يكون في مراقب من الامم المتحده في مرافق
اقليمي في مراقب على الاقل مثلا المندوبين
للسفارات الاجنبيه
72 ساعه ولا يومين ثلاثه حتى حتى يعني لا
يكون في يعني
معارف
الانفاق اطلاق النار حتى يعني موضوع كبير
ويحتاج الى وقت معقد انا قصدي يا استاذي
انا قصدي يا استاذي ان الهدنه بتحتاج الى
مراقبه لانه كل واحد من الجانبين ممكن
يعني يخرق هذه الهدنه باي سبب بعدين الان
الاجواء غير صالحه
لوجود تهودنا كامله مستدامه لانه يعرفوا
انا يعني مثلا الجيش السوداني ملتزم
بتحركاته
باتصالاته مع قواته في اي مكان الان يعني
اعرف انه قوات الدعم السريع هي مشتته في
الشوارع بالتالي كيف يعني تتلقى الاوامر
من قاداتها حتى هي تلتزم بهذه الهدنه يعني
الان الجو غير يعني ملائم لو كان هنالك
مثل جيشين بين دولتين كان ممكن الهدنه
تكون التزام على الحدود في المرشح الاكبر
لفعل ذلك باعتقادك اذا ما نوقش وقف لاطلاق
النار
وطرحت اسماء دول معينه او جنسيات معينه
يتم انتقاء منها عناصر لمراقبه وقف اطلاق
النار
عموما كما تعلم اخي الكريم دائما في تاريخ
الهدنان دائما الامور المتحده بالشكل قوات
من دول مختلفه يعني الام
كل كل الهدن التامه الدين اذا كان في في
كل الحروب اذا كان حتى في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط في افريقيا في بعض الدول يتم وجود
قوات من جنسيات مختلفه تكون محايده تماما
لا علاقه لها باي من الطرفين
حتى حتى يعني ممكن ناخذ اخر مثال في
السودان في دارفور كانت في قوات من الهند
في قوات من الدول الافريقيه هي شكلت يعني
مراقبه
اللاجئين وعدم ضربهم كده يعني فانا اعتقد
يعني كونه حفيده عاده هل تجارب السابقه
تقول بانه يمكن ان تكون ناجعه ومفيده تخدم
المرحله نعم واكيد يعني خطط للهدنه تكون
هناك خطوط معينه للتحرك الجيشين
المتصارعين يعني في وجود قوه محايده حتى
تراقب عن كسب يعني لا تخشى من انه عامل
عدم الحسم عدم انتصار طرف على طرف اخر
سيكرس الانقسام او التقسيم على خطوط تماس
معينه كي لا نقول تقسيم البلد بشكل كامل
وارد اخي الكريم وهو هذا حدث في ايام
الفطر ولا ايام الاولى كان في اختراق
بسبب عدم يعني اللي هو الشيابيه الاوامر
بالذات لقوات الدعم السريع طيب ما
المعلومات التي نملكها الان عن مدى ولاء
الجيش لكل تحركات البرهان او عن مدى ولاء
كل قيادات
حمايه للتصرفاته يعني
من الممارسات اليوميه في الشوارع يعني
الحالات التي تسجل نعم انت تعرفك اذا كان
الجيش ملتزم او قوات الدعم السريع يعني
انا اديت مثال
عفوا قبل المثال يعني انت تقول بانه
الطرفان ملتزمان بكل القيادات تبعهم
بذلك يصرحون بذلك انهم ملتزم
ين بالارض
ضعي الان باعتقادك الى اي مدى الجيش بكل
مؤسسته وضباطه وقياداته تعتقد بانه متماسك
وتحت لواء البرهان تماما الى اي مدى
باعتقادك كله راضي على ادائه وكذلك عند
الطرف الاخر الى اي مدى تعتقد بانه الكل
راضي في قيادات الدعم السريع عن توجهات
وتصرفات السيد حميدتي انت الان انت الان
انا اديك انت الان يعني
صورتين مختلفتين في السودان بانه محتلوا
بعض المواقع
وان الجيش السوداني
الانسيطروا عليها نعم او اعاده السيطره
عليها نعم
نتكلم عن الجيش السوداني عمره 100 سنه نعم
ويعتبر من افضل او اقوى 10 ضيوف في
افريقيا ورابع جيش على مستوى العالم
العربي ليش منظم وحتى لو جينا خلفيه في
نظام البشير السابق كان ينفق 70% من
ميزانيه الدوله السودانيه على الجيش
السوداني
فانا اعتقد انه الجيش موظف
وانت صادق فيه ولكن لا يعني انه لا يحصل
انقلابات تاريخ
السودان يعني هذا الجيش منظم وبواجه يعني
معلش قوات الدعم الشديد الذي هي يعني
عندها مساله الفروه يعني تقاتل وطهره
تقاتل وطهره يعني حتى ما عند الان مكان هي
مستوله عليه يعني من من المشاهات السياديه
يعني لو حصل
محسوم ولا المطار محسوم ولا القياده
العامه محسومه هذا مهم ايضا يعني حتى لو
لم تستولي عليها ولكنها قادره حتى الان
على فرد عدم سيطره الطرف الاخر الذي هو
الجيش
جميل جدا ولكن لا تنسى انه يعني الجيش لن
يستطيع ان يواجه يعني اسلوب حرب عصابات
كما تعلم يعني انت لو في اخر شيء حتى
المسلحه عندما كانت تقاتل الجيش السوداني
في دارفور لم يستطيع الجيش السوداني تحقيق
كامل عليها حتى بعد ما يعني الا بدل ال
400 قتيل كان كان عنا لا سمح الله اربعه
الاف قتيل يعني لو كان الجيش يريد ان يحسم
بشراسه
وكان معظمها من المدنيين الان باعتقادك
يعني بدانا باستماع الى هدى محتمله ومن
وعن اطراف دخلت على الخط ولكن كلما تقدمنا
في عدد الايام والاسابيع ربما والاشهر
يعني
ضعت طاسه اكثر ما الذي يمكن ان يعيد
الامور الى زمامها من جديد الان اي مبادره
اي طرح وممن
اتوقع ننتظر ننتظر جلسه المجلس الامن
الثلاثه ونعتقد هذه حتكون فيها قرارات
صارمه بعد ما رفض الطرفان من الالتزام
بالهنا انا اتوقع انه يوم الثلاثاء حتصدر
قرارات بحكم الطلب بريطانيا
بعقد جلسه طارئه لحل المشكله وانا اعتقد
انه بريطانيا تحركت بحكم علاقتها بالسودان
يعني دوله كانت مستعمره للسودان وعلاقتها
حاميه وزيد على ذلك التجمعات والتظاهرات
اللي حصلت اخيرا في بريطانيا في لندن من
السودانيين الموجودين هناك وكان له دور
فعل في تحريك المساله لكن علينا ان ننتظر
الى يوم الثلاثاء انا اعتقد انه حتكون
القرارات حتكون حاسمه وقويه في
الزقاق الطرفين وانا اعتقد مثلا حتكون فقط
عقوبات انا اعتقد انه حتكون ابعد من ذلك
سوء ابعد من ذلك يعني شو في ابعد من
العقوبات الفصل السابع تقصد انا توقعت
تدخل يعني حتى حتى انت حتى وزير دفاعنا في
مؤتمر الصحفي قال لدينا خيارات مختلفه
للتدخل في السودان هذا وزير الدفاع في
مؤتمر الاخير يعني وزير الدفاع
نعم اي وزير دفاع وزير الدفاع الولايات
المتحده في مؤتمر الصحفي الاخير الذين خي
ارات يعني لا ادري ربما هذا يعني مصطلح
يستخدمه الامريكيون عاده قد لا يرقى الى
لانه المواقف الاخرى لا تقول بذلك في تدرج
يعني بالمواقف عاده
بيختلف عن اي صراخ صراح يعني صراع حسن في
اي دوله افريقيه او دوله عربيه اذا كان
اليمن او ليبيا السودان عنده عمق
استراتيجي جغرافي
في ثمانيه دول
منها مصر
من بحر الاحمر منها ليبيا قصدي قولوا انه
ما كان واضح عند هذه الدول توجه للحسم
والا كانت مواقفهم اشرس من هيك بكثير
بتكون من البدايه حتى لو كانت تجاه اي طرف
من الطرفين لا ادري ولكن ليس هناك حسم في
التوازن حتى بموضوع العقوبات اللي شفناه
بدول اخرى تم بشكل سريع جدا لم يحصل في في
السودان لم يكن لديهم نيه واضحه للحسم
لتوجيه عصا مباشره
اللي شايفه حدث الان وممكن اقول على في
قناه العربيه اللي حصل يعني انا اللي اللي
استشفيته هل هذه الدول والعراسه امريكا
كانت الغرض من سحب رعاياها والبعثات
الدبلوماسيه اكثر من من امان الاستقرار او
بصه الاستقرار والامن للشعب السوداني هذا
هو السؤال المطروح يعني الدول استعجلت
كثيرا جدا في سحب رعاياها
وبعثات الدبلوماسيه اذا قارنتها باي احداث
قلت لك ظهرت في ليبيا او في العراق او في
اليمن او في اي دوله ثانيه او في سوريا
يعني استعجلوا في سحب رعاياهم
ولانه واضح ان الموقف يعني مرشح للتصعيد
المؤشر لانه
ستبقى معنا استاذنا اسمح لي يعني اكتفي
معك بهذا القدر للان ولكن لو تكرمت ابقى
معنا في هذه التغطيه
وسنعود اليك في سياقها ان شاء الله ما
يحدث في السودان لن يبقى داخله سباعيه
افريقيه قد تتاثر بتفاقم النزاع اكثر
فخروج ذوي الانفجارات وقتال الشوارع عن
مساحه المليون
و880 الف كيلو متر مربع ليس مستبعدا جوله
اولى من حرب اهليه قد تمتد الى سبع دول
يتشارك السودان حدودا ملتهبه معها
بالاستناد الى عاملين مدى استمراريه
النزاع ونتيجته
حقائب موظبه وصرر محموله على الراس احد
مخاوف السباعيه المحيطه بالسودان وليس
اكبرها كوابيس تتسرب عبر السدود وانابيب
المياه وتتمل بعتاد حركات مسلحه عبر
الحدود التي باتت بيئه اكثر خصوبه للتمرد
اجلس الانذار التي تدق اقليميا ودوليا لا
تنحصر بكون السودان ثالث اكبر دوله في
افريقيا بل انه يمتد عبر منطقه حيويه
جيوسياسيا غير مستقره وهشه ببعض اجزائها
مصر المتعطشه للمياه اكثر دوله عربيه
اكتظاظا بالسكان وتتشارك مع السودان
تاريخا من السياسه والتجاره والثقافه
ومياه النيل فضلا عن علاقات وثيقه بالجيش
واكثر من اربعه ملايين سودانيه على
اراضيها واي اضطراب بالعمق الاستراتيجي
لمصر من شانه عرقله الجهود المشتركه
للتوصل
بشان سد النهضه التهديد المائي ليس فقط ما
تشكله اثيوبيا بطموحاتها الكهرومائيه
فالمناوشات على الحدود غير منقطعه اصلا
وقد يتسبب النزاع بعوده التوتر بمنطقه
الفشجه الخصبه الحدوديه المتنازع عليها
تشاد الجاره الغربيه الفقيره تحتضن بالاصل
نحو 400 الف نازح سوداني جراء صراعات
سابقه اضيف اليهم اكثر من عشرين الفا
مؤخرا القلق التشادينابع من مخاوف امتداد
الازمه لمناطق استقبلت اللاجئين ومعظمهم
من دارفور فتاريخ تشاد طويل مع ميليشيات
الجنجويد التي شكلت نواه قوات احمد تي
قلق مشابه يتكون غربا مرتزقه ومسلح
ميليشيات سودانيون عادوا الى بلادهم بعد
لعب دور النشط في الصراع الليبي هؤلاء على
معرفه جيده بالساحه الليبيه ومطاردتهم
داخليا قد ترميهم على الحدود مجددا اما
جنوب السودان الدوله التي استقلت حديثا
فمخاوفها تتمثل ببدء عرقله الروابط
اللوجستيه لتصريف انتاجها النفطي البالغ
170 الف برميلا يوميا عبء اقتصادي قد
تزيده سوءا عوده جماعيه لاكثر من 800 الف
لاجئ يستضيفهم السودان ازمه تتشاركها مع
اريتريا فمئه الفا من مواطنيها قد يضطرون
لحزم امتعتهم من جديد
معنا من القاهره الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني عادل ابراهيم حمد اهلا بك معنا
استاذ عادل هل تمكنت من التواصل في الساعه
الاخيره مع الداخل
معلومات
مهمه استطيع ان نستفيد منها في التحليل
وفي قراءه المشهد نعم استاذ عادل يعني
الاتصالات شبه مقطوعه مع الداخل كنت سالتك
اذا كنت تستطيع تتمكن من التواصل في هذا
اليوم في الساعه الاخيره
ربما الصوره الان خاطئه على الهواء نعود
الى استاذ عادل عادل
نعم استاذ عادل بالنسبه تفضل
المعلومات المتاحه يعني
معلومات خاصه ولكن المعلومات المتاحه من
عن
الوضع العسكري والامني في الخرطوم
والوضع الانساني ايضا
معلومات مفتوحه
وبصفه عامه
الوضع العسكري يكاد يكون يراوح مكانه بين
اذكار
الان حسب رايي وقراءته المشهد اصلا كنت
اتوقع منذ بدايه المعارك كان
يتفوق الجيش على قوات الدعم السريع بما له
من تفوق في العتاد والتدريب والخبرات
وهذا رايته اردده في كل لقاء
والان مع مرور الوقت
يتضح لي ان الجيش قد حقق فعلا تفوقا على
قوات الدعم السريع ولكن بما ان المعارك في
داخل المدينه
يصعب انهاء او الوصول
لنهايتها الحاسمه ما دام توجد جماعات
مشتثه وهي ممكن ان تخلق ازعاج سواء كان
الوضع العسكري او من ناحيه الوضع الامني
مفهوم وترويع المواطنين
اين تعتبر الانجاز الاهم اللي حققوا حتى
الان ما دام لم يستطع بعد السيطره بشكل
كامل على المؤسسات الاساسيه التي نتحدث
عنها يوميا القياده والمطار والقصر
اصلا هو الجيش الان في معركه
فاصله بين الجيش وبين القوات الدعم
السريعه التي يفترض ان تكون فرعا
لجيش بحكم اسمه انها نعم
وليست هي اصل القوى او ليست اصل المنظومه
العسكريه في السودان فهي فرع للجيش وعليه
فتعتبر قوات مارقه على الجيش ولابد للجيش
في هذه الحاله ان يحقق مصر حاسما على قوه
يعتبرها متمرده نعم فاي انا لا اتحدث في
المبدا اتحدث في التفصيل الان انت قلت
بانه حقق انجازات في توصيل في توصيل اين
هي هذه الانجازات باعتقادك من الناحيه
العسكريه يعني اين يعتبر العسكريون انهم
حققوا انجازا
نعم نحن ممكن نعتبر ذلك من
منطلق اخر وهو عدم تحقيق قوات الدعم
السريع لهدفها المعلن وهو الاطاحه بقائده
الجيش واعتقاله تقديمه لمحاكمه فانا اربط
هذا التصريح الصريح
بموقف سياسي
لقائد الدعم السريع من علاقه خاصه
بقوه سياسيه محدده وهي القوه التي هندسه
وضعت الاتفاق الايطالي الذي ظل قائد الدعم
السريع يعلن بوضوح انه يدعمه وبالتالي
اصبح وكانه يريد ان يفرض هذا الحل السياسي
بعمل عسكري وذلك بازاحه قائد
الجيش وهو قائد مجلس السياده سؤالي لك
الان ما دام انت تقول ذلك لماذا باعتقادك
اراد ان يفرض ذلك عسكريا لو لم يشع ر بان
الطرف الاخر وهو ما يقوله
ان الطرف الاخر لم يرد ان يحقق للسياسيين
ذلك واراد التنصل من الاتفاق الاطاري
بالتالي ما رايك
هلا واضح انه القوات المسلحه المنظومه
العسكريه لم تكن مؤيده لاتفاق الايطالي
باعتبار انه في الاتفاق الايطالي بنودا
تحجم الجيش حسب راي المنظومه العسكريه
وتضعه تحت قياده الرئيس الوزراء المدني
وتؤجل دمع دمج القوات الدعم السريع لمده
عشر سنوات بدل عامين كما كان يقترح الجيش
وبصفه عامه العسكريين العسكريون لهم
حساسيه خاصه تجاه التدخل المدنيين في شارع
عسكري
وبين عسكري والمدنيين بصفه عامه حساسيات
كثيره جدا
والمنظومه العسكريه كانت ترى ان
المدنيين في السودان
وليست المجتمع المدني كله ولا المدني كله
بل
عدد محدود من الاحزاب السياسيه التي تقود
والحريه والتغيير ميزه المركزي
هي التي
قدمت هذه الرؤيه وهناك
غير متفقه مع
القوه والحريه والتغيير المركزي في هذه
الرؤيه فهذا الانقسام بين القوى المدنيه
انعكس ايضا في انقسام اخر في القوه
العسكريه ويبدو لي يبدو لي ان
القوه الحريه والتغيير ميزه المركزي بعد
ان طالب الانقلاب العسكري وفرض وجوده رات
اللابد من وجود قيار عسكري اه او قوه
عسكريه اخرى تلاحظ هذا الانقلاب وتبطله
فراحت على قوات الدعم السريع وارى انه
رهان كان
رهان خاسرا
[موسيقى]
رهنت اذا هي التي حرضت السيد حميد
باعتقادك على اتخاذ مثل هذا الخيار
عليه راهنت عليه وهو الان يتحدث لغه
سياسيه الان قيد الدعم السريع يتحدث عن
انه يريد ان ينقل السودان
نقل الديمقراطي او ينقله الى دوله مدنيه
ديمقراطيه وهذا حديث لا يتسق مع تاريخ
قائد الدعم السريع
ولم يعرف انه مفكر ولا يعرف عن قوات الدعم
السريع نفسها انها قوه مناضله ذات رؤيه
وذات الطرف الاخر ايضا اعتمد على الحركات
المسلحه وعلى الكتله الديمقراطيه اليس
كذلك
المنظومه العسكريه اصلا لم تصلح نفسها
منظومه سياسيه ولكنها هي الان شريك في في
الفتى الانتقاليه
وبعد بعد انقلاب خمسه اشهر اكتوبر
الذي فرض واقعا جديدا بغض عنه فعلا مشروع
او غير مشروعه واكيد انا اؤكد في حسب رايي
انا مع الراي القائل بان الانقلاب فعل غير
مشروع ولكن في السياسه قد يفرض الفعل غير
المشروع واقعا جديدا فالواقع الجيد قد فعل
غير مشروع وهذا بالنسبه للانقلاب
وراهنت قوى الحريه والتغيير عن العمل
الجماهيري
لفشال هذا الانقلاب ولكن مع مرور الوقت
يعني اجاباتك مره مع هذا الطرف ومره مع
الاخر عم تحاول تعطي تحليل منطقي واقعي
يعني للامور لانه احيانا تقف مع
الجيش والسيد البرهان واحيانا تقف مع
الطرف الاخر في كل ما تقوله حتى بين
القوتين سياسيتين يعني
لا انا انا مع الراي القائل بانه الانقلاب
في الغير مشروع والقوه المدنيه انت هذه
حقيقه ولكن القوى المدنيه بعد ان قاومت
هذا الانقلاب بعمل جماهيري ثبت عمليا على
ارض الواقع عن انغلاق ثبت اقدامه اكثر
والعمل الجماهيري لم يوهن الانقلاب
فرات هذه القوه حسب رايي ان تستعين بقوه
عسكريه اخرى لاجها الانقلاب لذلك ما قالت
لقوه
القوات الدعم السريع
واوهمت قائد الدعم سريعا انه يمكن ان يكون
ظهيرا عسكريا ويمكن ان يكون له مستقبل
عسكري وسياسي اذا راهن على قوى الحريه
والتغيير وهذا واضح في احاديث وتصريح
والاخير بانه يريد ان ينقل السودان الى
حق الانتقال العسكريه هي التي تستخدم
السياسيين وليس العكس يعني وكانك تح بعض
القوى السياسيه اكثر مما تحتمل في ازمه
عسكريه طاحنه فيها الكثير من المشاريع
الداخليه والخارجيه في الكثير من الطموحات
ايضا الشخصيه الداخليه والخارجيه
هذا صحيح ولكن هذا العمل ليس عسكريا صرفا
هذا العمل له جذور سياسيه
صحيح جدا شكرا جزيلا لك تبقى معنا لو
تكرمت عادل ابراهيم حمد الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي السوداني من القاهره
استمرت عمليات اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب من
الخرطوم الى بورتسودان كما رصدتها العربيه
من ولايه البحر الاحمر الجيش السوداني وضع
مسارين للاجلاء عبر المطار والميناء
البحري في بورسودان وقال مراسل العربيه
هناك ان اكثر من ثماني طائرات حطت في مطار
بورتسودان خلال ساعات لتنفيذ الاجلاء
اعلن وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه جيمس كلي
عن اغلاق السفاره البريطانيه في الخرطوم
مؤقتا مؤكدا ان سلامه البريطانيين في
السودان تشكل اولويه قصوى بالنسبه اليهم
لقد اتخذنا قرارا باغلاق السفاره
البريطانيه في الخرطوم مؤقتا واجلاء
الدبلوماسيين البريطانيين وعائلاتهم ونقل
وظائفنا الدبلوماسيه الى موقع دبلوماسي
قريب ونواصل العمل بشكل مباشر من خلال
شركائنا الدوليين للدعوه الى وقف اطلاق
النار ووضع حد لهذا العنف تبقى سلامه
حمايه الرعايه البريطانيه في السودان
اولويه قصوى بالنسبه لنا وسنقوم بهذا
الواجب من خلال سفاراتنا الموجوده في
المنطقه بالتنسيق الوثيق مع اصدقائنا
وشركائنا الدوليين
من جانبه اكد وزير الدفاع البريطاني بان
عمليه اجلاء الموظفين دبلوماسيين
البريطانيين وعائلاتهم تمت بنجاح مشيرا
الى انه شارك في عمليه الاجلاء اكثر من
1200 شخص
الليله الماضيه اجرى الجيش البريطاني
عمليه اجلاء للموظفين الدبلوماسيين
البريطانيين وعائلاتهم من الخرطوم
باستخدام عناصر من اللواء السادس عشر هجوم
جوي وسلاح الجو الملكي ومشات البحريه
الملكيه ساهم اكثر من 1200 شخص في هذه
العمليه المحفوفه بالمخاطر لكننا مع ذلك
تمكنا من استخدام طائرات سيئه
للدخول وجمع دبلوماسيين والمقيمين معهم
والطيران الى بر الامان
من باريس مدير مكتب العربيه حسين قنيبر
اهلا بك معنا حسين تطلعنا لو سمحت على اخر
ما نعرفه حول
الاجلاء الفرنسي تحديدا
مساء الخير طاهر قبل الدخول في تفاصيل ما
تناوله البيان المشترك الصادر مساء اليوم
عن وزارتي الخارجيه والدفاع الفرنسيتين
اشير الى ما نسب قبل قليل الى هيئه اركان
الجيوش الفرنسيه لناحيه اشارتها الى ان
عمليه الاجلاء في الجانب السوداني منها
وقبل وصول 100 شخص علامات طائره تابعه
لسلاح الجو الفرنسي من السودان الى جيبوتي
مساء اليوم الجانب السوداني من عمليه
الاجلاء كان مثيرا بحيث ان وحدات عسكريه
فرنسيه وصلت مسبقا وقبل بدء عمليه الاجلاء
الى محيط الخرطوم بالتنسيق مع الطرفي
النزاع في السودان وقامت هذه الوحدات
العسكريه الفرنسيه بعملها
بحياد تام كما قالت هيئه اركان الجيوش
الفرنسيه الليله دون ان تعطي التفاصيل
اضافيه الخارجيه الفرنسيه طاهر قد تجنبت
الاجابه على سؤال حول تعرض الموكب الفرنسي
برا قبل وصوله الى المطار لاطلاق نار ادى
الى جرح فرنسي مع ان هذه المعلومه ذكرتها
صحيفه المعروفه بمصداقيتها الا ان
الخارجيه الفرنسيه ولاسباب مفهومه تتعلق
بعدم الرغبه في تعريض من بقي من الفرنسيين
في السودان لاي مخاطر قبل انتهاء عمليه
الاجلاء لهذا السبب تكتمت الخارجيه
الفرنسيه على ما حصل لكن مصدرا في وزاره
الدفاع لم ينفي الليله تعرض موكب الاجلاء
الفرنسي لاطلاق نار لم ينفي هذا الخبر
الذي تداولته وسائل الاعلام لكنه لم يقدم
اي تفاصيل بشانه ويبدو ان اطلاق النار حصل
فعلا ويعتقد انه ادى الى جرح فرنسي طاهر
البيان المشترك الان نعود اليه الصادر عن
وزارتي الخارجيه او الدفاع اشار الى انه
وبالتنسيق بين سفاره
مركز الازمات والدعم التابع لوزاره
الخارجيه هنا في باريس قام العسكريون
الفرنسيون بتنسيق وصول 100 شخص على متن
رحله تابعه لسلاح الجو الفرنسي شكر بيان
الخارجيه والدفاع الجهود التي بذلتها
سلطات جيبوتي والتي قامت بمساعده حاسمه
جعلت عمليه الاجلاء ممكنه كما جاء في هذا
البيان عمليه الاجلاء ستتواصل في الساعات
48 المقبله طاهر اذا نتحدث عن مراحل
لعمليه الاجلاء كما
هي حاله دول اخرى بحسين هل هناك اي جديد
يتعلق بموقف الفرنسي السياسي من استمرار
هذا الصراع المسلح بين الطرفين في السودان
سياسيا الفرنسيون يتجنبون الادلاء
بتصريحات قد يفهم منها انهم يقفون مع هذا
الطرف ضد الطرف المقابل ولكنهم يتحدثون عن
نزاع مفتوح زمنيا هذا ما قاله مصدرا بعد
ظهر اليوم في وزاره الخارجيه ووزاره
الدفاع مبررين الاتصالات الكثيفه التي
يقوم بها الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون مع عده
جهات اقليميه ودوليه قال المصدران ان
النزاع يبدو مفتوحا في السودان وكانت
الخارجيه الفرنسيه في تصريحات لتاتريس
بالتواصل باللغه العربيه في الخارجيه كان
صرح للعربيه ان ما يجري في السودان نعتبره
خطيرا جدا ليس فقط على السودانيين وانما
ايضا على المنطقه برمتها لانه يهدد
الاستقرار فيها وهذا ما يقلقنا لهذه
الاسباب مجتمعه طاهر الرئيس ماكرون ووزيره
الخارجيه كاترين كولونا اجر اتصالات اجريا
اتصالات خلال الساعات الماضيه والايام
القليله الماضيه بكل من السعوديه ومصر
والامارات والامين العام للجامعه العربيه
والمانيا والولايات المتحده بهدف محاوله
حث طرفي النزاع في السودان الى وقف اطلاق
النار هذه الليله اعلنت الخارجيه الفرنسيه
وايضا وزاره الدفاع ان كل اجهزه الدوله
الفرنسيه ستبقى مستنفره بانتظار الشروع في
عمليه اجلاء جديده بعد العمليه التي جرت
اليوم ويعتقد انه صباح غدا ستكون هناك
عمليه اجلاء جديده في اطار سلسله من
عمليات الاجلاء يفترض ان تنتهي خلال
الساعات الثمانيه والاربعين المقبله كما
ذكرت اذا الموقف الفرنسي قد يعني لا يكون
تفصيليا بعد في مواضيع متعلقه بموزه هجره
جديده بات يخشى منها بعض الاوروبيين اذا
ما استمر الصراع من الجنوب الى الشمال ومن
كذلك امكانيه استحداث بؤره ارهاب جديده
بين قوسين اذا ما تسلل متطرفون الى
السودان واستغلوا الصراع القائم حاليا
بطبيعه الحال بدون ادنى شك هذا مسار قلق
عاده لفرنسا والدول الاوروبيه ولكن يعني
قد لا يبدو منعكسا كثيرا في التصريحات حتى
الان
ليس منعكسا كثيرا تماما طاهر لانه على
المدى القصير الاولويه الفرنسيه هي لحمايه
امن الفرنسيين الموجودين في السودان ولا
الاتصالات السياسيه بهدف التوصل الى وقف
لاطلاق النار يمهد بدوره لهدنا دائما
فرنسا تقول طالما انك تسال عن الجانب
السياسي ان الحل يكون اولا بالعوده الى
عمليه سياسيه شامله وثانيا تشكيل حكومه
انتقاليه مدنيه ثم اجراء انتخابات عامه
لكن هذه المراحل الثلاث لن تكون ممكنه ما
لم يعتمد الطرفان ما لم يحترم الطرفان
وقصى اطلاق نار دائم وقف اطلاق نار غير
فوري ويكون له طابع انساني على الاقل
للسماح بسحب جثث الضحايا وبسحب الجرحى
وباجلاء الرعايه الاجانب من السودان هذا
هو الموقف الفرنسي حتى الان والاتصالات
الفرنسيه مستمره في الايام المقبله مع كل
الاطراف السودانيه والاقليميه والدوليه
طاهر شكرا جزيلا لك حسين قنيبر مدير مكتب
العربيه في باريس تحياتي اليك
اعلن المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في
السودان خالد عمر يوسف ان النزاع الحالي
في السودان سيكون سببا في ضياع البلاد دون
استعادتها مؤكدا انها حرب لن ينتصر فيها
اي طرف اشار ايضا الى ما اعتبرها فرصه
متاحه حاليا لايقاف الحرب وتشكيل جبهه
مدنيه لتجاوز الازمه الراهنه كما اكد على
اهميه واولويه الاجتماع اجتماع الاطراف
العسكريه والمدنيه على طاوله الحوار
للتوصل الى حل دائم
اتهامات متبادله بين قائد الجيش السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم
السريعه محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف بحميتي
فخلال لقائهما غير المباشر عبر العربيه
اتهم كل طرف الطرف الاخر ببدء الحرب وخرق
الهدنه والهجوم على منازل السكان والبعثات
الاجنبيه
البرهان وحماتي جنرالاني جنح الى الحرب
بعد ان كان السودان قاب قوسين او ادناه من
توقيع اتفاق تاريخي العربيه جمعت البرهان
وحماتي على شاشتها في حوار غير مباشر
بينهما في مقابلتين خاصتين من بدا الحرب
احنا كنا موجودين في مقراتنا وتم الهجوم
علينا من قبل هذه المجموعات المتمرده
من يسيطر على العاصمه وما ابرز اماكن وجود
قوات كل طرف
[موسيقى]
الاحياء السكنيه
المهندسين
اين يوجد البرهان وحميتي
ولمضارحه ول
ن اضع هذه هي مهنتي وهذا
شرف لن اخرج الا محمولا على نعش
من خلق الهدنه اي هدنه اعلنت اصلا
يعني القوات الطرف الاخر غير مسيطر عليها
وهي منتشره في مناطق مختلفه من الحياه
السكنيه
من اختار الحرب عوض السلام
نقول موجودين في الغارات وتم الهجوم علينا
من قبل هذه المجموعات المتمرده طبعا
نحن نقوم بالدفاع ولا نريد ان نخرج نخرج
الى خارج دائره الدفاع
البرهان
من يستهدف المستشفيات والبعثات الاجنبيه
لدعم السريع اخرجت المواطنين في المنازل
اخرجت اخلط المستشفيات واحتلت المستشفيات
كيف ستنتهي المعركه
لم تعلم
الى هذه الحرب انا اقول ان هذه الحرب ليس
فيها كاسد
نعود الى رياض مع محمود لعوطه الكاتب
الصحفي السوداني اهلا بك معنا استاذ محمود
عامل الزمن في صالح من هنا
ليس بصالح احد ولكن طبعا اذا امتدت الحظ
انا اعتقد انه الجيش هو الخاص يعني لانه
بمعنى لماذا يعني
هو مطالب بانه في البلاد نعم يعني حتى
يعني حتى رئيس مسياده كان بيتمثل بانه هو
مسؤول عن استبداد الامن في السودان
باعتباره قائد الجيش السوداني
طيب انت ما كانت ابرز ماخذك بالامس على
خطابي الرجلين على شاشه العربيه يعني
الاستفسارات التي كانت لديك او تساؤلات
التي كانت لديك عما يقولان
يعني انا انا سمحت للحوارين واستمت
للتلخيص اللي عملته انت الان انا اعطاني
كنت اتمنى انه الرجلان بدل ان يعني يطلقان
التصريحات الصحفيه تصريحات الناريه هذه
على الفضائيات
التلفزيونيه كان من من الافضل ان
يجلسان ويتحاوران
ويتواضعا ما دامهم مهتمين بالشان السوداني
يعني بمعنى انه
لا يتبادل الاتهامات وان يجلس على طاوله
التفاوض مجددا
الاتحاد والمقابلات الصحفيه هذه الضخمه
التي يتابعها كل العالم كنت اتمنى كان كل
واحد منهم يتبادر ويقول للاخر تعالي الى
طاوله يعني لو نزحت طاوله المفاوضات لما
اشتبكوا يعني في الشارع ولكن السؤال الان
باعتقادك هل هناك امكانيه للعوده الى
الوراء الى ما قبل 15 من ابريل هل هناك
امكانيه لكي يجلس البرهان مجددا مع حميته
على طاوله التفاوض
تغير تماما الان هذه
النقطه منعطفه
تحول كبير جدا في الشان السوداني او في
الساحه السودانيه نحن كنا منتظرين اربع
سنوات
يتفقوا هؤلاء امام اذا دخلوا في نفق
الرصاص والبنادق الامر الرجوع يكون صعبا
يعني هل توافق ما كان يتفضل به ضيفنا من
القاهره بانه هذا الموضوع جزء منه سياسي
او جذره سياسي وليس مشروعات عسكريه او
طموحات شخصيه او خارجيه تطبق في البلاد
والخلافه السياسي ادى الى الصراع العسكري
يعني تتوافق معه اذا هو سياسي
الخلافه السياسي
شو يعني باي معنى على اي مشروع يعني
الخلاف السياسي بده يكون في مشروع بده
يكون في فكره عقيده على سور خلاف يا استاذ
طاهر هو ما كانوا متفقين
لماذا اختلف لانه اختلفت المصالح
اللي هي شو المصالح يعني
الموضوع سياسي
كل واحد
يريد يقود السوداني
بطريقته التي يراها يعني الان صراع الان
الصراع اصبح بين اذا هذا استخدام
ويعني الرامات في العيون يريدون ان يقولوا
للناس انه المشكله مع في السياسيين بينما
المشكله في طبيعه الدمج ومده الدمج
والموضوع عسكري
لا انا انا كان يعني ممكن اقول لك مهم جدا
بعد ما سقط بنظام البشير بامانه حدث فراغ
سياسي في السودان لا يوجد قاده سياسيين
كانوا يقودوا المساله السودانيه ويطرح
الحلول وهذه المشكله هذا الفراغ سبب انه
تدخلات من القوى العسكريه او من الجيش
يعني الطريقه السياسي هذا خلى القاده في
الجيش يسكن في كان في قيادات شفت شو صار
بخمسه وعشرين اكتوبر بغض النظر عن مدى
حقيقه ذلك طب ما كان في جيش حاكم يعني
سياسيين ما كان عندهم القدره ان يتصرفوا
كما يشاؤون يعني لماذا دائما وضع اللوم
على سياسيين كان بامكان الجيش باي وقت ان
يدخل اليهم ويحبسهم
سابقه كم مره حصلت ثوره شعبيه في السودان
كثيرا
كثيرا وكان كان السياسيين متواجدين وكان
الحل سريع مثل اذا قارنته بالان مختلف
تماما
مختلف تماما كانت في مطروحات كانت تفيق في
في قاده سياسيين لديهم البعض والكلمه
والسماع من في الاوساط السياسيه يعني كانت
كلمتهم مسموعه تمام
مقبوله اذا جيت رجعت للتاريخ اما الان
الوضع يختلف ثمانيه
حتى يعني يعني هلا ما عندك صادق المهدي
وما عندك الحسن الترابي وما عندك كثير
شخصيات اخرى كانت لها تاريخ في تاريخ بغض
النظر عن توجهاتهم يعني
بس قامات كانوا يعني
على مستوى على مستوى القياده السياسين كان
هنالك قاده عسكريين يتفهمون الموقف
المدنيين يعني مثال لذلك لحد الان يتحدث
عنه التاريخ وتحدث عنه السودانيين وتحدث
عنه العالم والعالم العربي موقف سوار
الذهب من ثوره ابريل سالت هذا السؤال
للسيد البرهان عندما قابلته في الخرطوم
وقال لي لا نعم اريد ان اكون سوار الذهب
اخر هل تعتقد انه الايام تثبت كلامه
لا في ظل الان الامر معقد المشهد المشهد
صعب ومعقد لانه تدخلت فيه بعض الجهاد التي
ايضا تمنح ان تقود السودان يعني انا صراحه
اقول لك انا كصحفي انقل لك تساؤلات في
الشارع السوداني لماذا تمدد قائله الدعم
السريع حماديه بهذا الشكل
بهذا الشكل كان مركزه عليه ان يكافح او
يقاوم الحركات المسلحه ولكن هذا الرجل ان
تمدد وباعين وبحضور البرهان تمدد في كل
مطبقه على السودان كانت له كل قواعد في
السودان لماذا يعني هذا سؤال مطروح من كل
السودان على فكره كل ما تدخل بيت سودانيه
او مجتمع السوداني او جلسات سودانيه
يتساءلون لماذا تمدد قائد الدعم السريع
بهذه الصوره السريعه وهذا السؤال الذي كنا
نطرحه على الاقل منذ بدايه هذه الحرب يعني
لماذا سمح الجيش هو السيد البرهان بهذا
بكل هذا التمدد
ولماذا لا اجابه للاسف
لا لماذا عندما اتفق البرهان مع حميتي
لقياده اللي هو التغيير يعني بعد بعد
الليل الامنيه لماذا لم يقل البرهان
لحمديه ادمج الدعم السريع في الجيش
السوداني ونكون جيش واحد لماذا من البدايه
لم يطرح هذه
المساله وتكون هنالك طموحات شو رايك نشرك
استاذ عادل معنا بالحوار لعله لديه بعض
الاجابات نشرك استاذ عادل ابراهيم حمد
الكاتب والمحدث السياسي السوداني من
القاهره معنا في هذا الحوار لعله يملك بعض
الاجابات استاذ عادل
كنت استمع الى الحوار
تفضل نعم نلخص جذر الازمه
في عباره في عباره واحده هي عدم تحمل
الاستحقاق الديمقراطي ايوه هذه الثوره
الثوره ديسمبر
هذه الثوره كانت ضد نظام شمولي
وبالتالي فان اهم الاهداف التي يفترض ان
تحققها للثوره هي تحرير الانتقال
الديمقراطي في السودان
ولكن
وكان فتره انتقاليه منذ بدايتها هي من
مكونين المكونه العسكري الذي اصبح شريكا
في الثوره بحكم انحياز الجيش للثوار
والمكون المدني الذي قاد قاده التجمع
المهني السودانيين
واصبح هنالك للشراكه المعروفه
بس لو سمحت اشير الى وصول اولى طائرات
الاجلاء الاردنيه القادمه من السودان الى
عمان العاصمه الاردنيه اذن هذه الصور
نشاهدها وقد وصلتنا لوصول اولى طائرات
الاجلاء القادمه الاردنيه القادمه من
السودان الى العاصمه الاردنيه عمان وفقا
للخبر الذي افادنا به مراسل العربيه عمار
الهندي معنا الان مراسل العربيه من عمان
عمار ماذا لديك
عمار اذا اي تفاصيل عن وصول اولى طائرات
الاجلاء الاردنيه القادمه من السودان الى
عمان ونحن نتابع هذه الصور التي افتونا
بها نعم
وصلت الاربع طائرات التي تتم الاردنيين
القادمين من السودان بالاضافه الى عدد من
الجنسيات العربيه والاجنبيه هذه الطائرات
الاربعه كانت يعني
توجهت من بورشيدان الى العاصمه الاردنيه
عام وتحمل 3343
شخصا ثلاث مئه منهم اردنيين و43 شخص من
جنسيات مختلفه جنسيات فلسطينيه عراقيه
سوريه وايضا المانيه هذه الخطه التي جرت
لاقامه فيها الحكومه الاردنيه بالتعاون مع
المؤسسات الاردنيه من الاجهزه الامنيه من
المخابرات والجيش كانت اعتمدت على نقل
المواطنين الاردنيين من المدن السودانيه
الى بورسودان برا وبعد ذلك كان توجه
طائرات العسكريه التابعه لسلاح الجو
الملكي الاردني الى بورسودان وقامت بنقل
هؤلاء المواطنين التي يعني هبطت للثور في
مطار ماركا العسكري طاهر طبعا كانت هذه
الطائرات
ثلاث مرات لاحتياطات امنيه حسب ما فهمنا
كان من المفرده تهبط في العاصمه عمان
الخامسه مساء تاخرت الى السابعه وعلى
التاسعه وصلنا الى هذه الساعه 12:30
تقريبا الواحده الا ربع تقل كما قلت لك
300 اردني من اصل
450 اردنيا يقيمون على الاراضي السودانيه
طبعا هنالك 150 اردنيا طاهر كانوا يعني
طلبوا البقاء
صابئه رغم الاحداث الجاريه هناك
وابلغوا السلطات الاردنيه برغبتهم في
البقاء بالسودان و300 منهم غادروا ووصلوا
للتو كما سيحدث الان طاهر هو ان سينزل
هؤلاء الذين تم اجزاؤهم من الاراضي
السودانيه فيدخل الى مبنى المطارج فتختم
جوازاترهم بطريقه
وبعد ذلك سيغادروا الامن طلب من الجميع من
جميع المؤسسات الصحفيه عدم التحدث واجراء
مقابلات مع المسافرين الا بعد ان يسلموا
اجراءات سفرهم وخفي الجوازاتهم وكلام
والنقل حقائبهم الى داخل مبنى مطار ماركه
العسكري وهذه العمليه طاهر بهذه اللحظات
تكون انهت الحكومه الاردنيه
للتعاون مع المركز الوطني لاداره الازمات
والاجهزه الامنيه اجلاء الرعايه الاردنيين
في هذا طاقم احد طواقم الطائره يعني نزل
للتو الذي كان يقول هذه الطائره العسكريه
وجاء بها من السودان الى العاصمه عمان كما
قلت لك يكون بذلك الاردن قد انهى اجلاء
300 اردني من 450 هؤلاء الثلاثه وافقوا
هذه هذه صور الرعايه الان بداوا بالخروج
ظاهر من الطائره انت ستشاهد ستحاول
الكاميرا طبعا على كل امكانيه
كان تحدث عن انه السلطات اتخذت هذا القرار
نعم سمح لنا يعني هم يسمحوا لنا بالاقتراب
لتصويرهم
نعم هذا هذا طاقم العسكريين الاردنيين
يحمل اطفال
تم نقلهم الى الاراضي الاردنيه
اخرى طبعا يعني
يمنع التحدث اليهم الان لانه هذا بناء على
طلب مفهوم الجيش الاردني طلب عدم التحدث
اليهم والاستماع طبعا انت تعلم ان هنالك
قصص بالتاكيد لديهم الكثير يعني يقولون
لما شاهدوه ربما من احداث مخيفه ومفزعه
هناك في الاراضي السودانيه التي نتمنى
طبعا يعني ان يعود لها الهدوء طبعا وزاره
الخارجيه الاردنيه
واكمل بانه تفضل عمار تفضل نعم نعم حول
رائحة شوي
كنت اريد فقط ان اقول لانه بهذه في هذه
اللحظات يكون الاردن قد انهى اجلاء رعاياه
من السودان
وفيما يتعلق ببقيه الاردنيين هناك هم 150
اردنيا هم طلبوا البقاء على الاراضي
السودانيه نعم اليك طاهر ونبقي الصوره من
عندك شكرا على كل هذه المعلومات ولكن تبقى
معنا عمار اذا كان المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الاردنيه سنان المجالي قد اعلن
ان السلطات سلطات المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه اتخذت قرارا باجلاء رعاياها
المتواجدين على الاراضي السودانيه كما قال
عمار قبل قليل 300 شخص وانه بسبب استمرار
الاشتباكات وكان اعلن انه وزاره الخارجيه
والمغتربين بالتعاون مع الوزارات الاخرى
تابعت اوضاع المواطنين الاردنيين في
السودان منذ اول ايام الازمه نظرا للوضع
السائد في البلاد وتقرر البدء في عمليه
اجلاء الرعايه الاردنيين الموجودين في
السودان وكما قال اذا وكما اشرنا سيجري
شخص تمت هذه العمليه الان وقد وصلوا الى
المطار في عمان وستكون اكبر عمليه من
نوعها في تاريخ المملكه الحديث كما وصفها
المجالي كما اشار الى انه من اجل تنظيم
العمليه ايضا
نسقط السلطات الاردنيه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات العربيه المتحده
للحصول على المساعده وطبعا كانت دول اخرى
قامت بالمثل في هذا الوضع وارسلت طائراتها
ونسقت مع دول اخرى من اجل اجلاء مواطنيها
ودبلوماسييها من السودان بسبب عنف
الاشتباكات الى عمار الان مجددا عمار تفضل
طاهر اولا دعني سريعا اقول انت اردني
حضرتك اردني حمد لله على سلامتك الله
يسلمك ويبارك فيك كيف كانت رحلتكم اولا
والله اول حاجه معاك محمد فواز يوسف
المعايطه اهلا الاردني مقيم في الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
مقيم في الخرطوم واحنا اولا نحمد الله على
نعمه الاسلام وبنحمد الله على انه احنا
اردنيين في هالجهود الطيبه انا وانا اود
ان اتحدث اليك ولكن الامن الامن يمنع ان
اتحدث اليك في هذه اللحظات الا بعد ان
تختم جواز سفرك وبالتالي سانتظرك واتحدث
اليك بكل التفاصيل واسمع الى جهاتك طاهر
يعني انا للاسف انه يعني الامن يصر بان لا
نجري اي لقاء الا بعد ان يختم كل من وصلوا
جوازات سفرهم وبالتالي يتمم اجراءاتهم
القانونيه وبعد ذلك سنتحدث اليهم ساجور في
الكاميرا اترك لك الكلام وساجول في
الكاميرا تشاهد معنا الصور من مطار ماركه
العسكري تمام عمار اذن نشاهد يعني على
الاقل انك اصريت وحاولت كالعاده
مشكور ومتفهم موقفك في هذه الظروف ومتفاهم
ايضا موقف الامن هناك في هذه الظروف طبعا
عمليات اجلاء يعني كما وصفها المتحدث باسم
وزاره الخارجيه هي الاكبر اكبر عمليه من
نوعها في تاريخ المملكه الحديث تم اجلاء
300 اردني على الاقل من السودان اضافه الى
عدد اخر من جنسيات اخرى بالتنسيق مع الدول
الاخرى هي السعوديه والامارات كما اعلن
نتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الذي يعني
بكلامه وبشاهدتنا لهذه الصور الان تكون
هذه العمليه قد تمت لجهه
يعني الموجودين الاردنيين في اهل في
السابق ونحن معك عمار
انا اتحدث الى احد يعني الاخوان الاردنيين
الذين وصلوا اول شيء اتعرف عليك عبد
الجليل عصام عرفه ونعم الحمد لله على
السلامه اولا كيف كيف كانت الرحله سهله
ولا تغلبت متعبه والله الحمد لله نوعا ما
ممتازه يعني الشباب ما شاء الله ما قصروا
طواله وصلنا المطار على طول عملوا لنا
الدخول وطلعنا على الطياره والحمد لله
امورنا تمام نقلكم برا من الخرطوم الى
بورت سودان وبعد ذلك بالطائرات احكي لنا
بس شوي ايش التفاصيل بدي اسمع منك ايش
الاوضاع هناك لانه الناس حابه تسمع ايش
اللي بصير فعلا على الاراضي السودانيه
والشيء الوضع كان جدا صعب القصه صارت فجاه
يعني كنا نشعر بتوتر
بس يعني زي ما تولدت ساعه الصفر فجاه
من المعارك من القصف من بيتي كان جنب
المطار بالضبط منطقه اسمها بري ببعد عن
المطار تقريبا اثنين كيلو بس يعني باخر
الشارع بكون شايف المطار الرئيسي
انت فعلا اللي بنسمعه انه في جثث بالشوارع
في قتل كثير قصف في جثث في يعني حتى واحنا
مروحين على الطريق كان في يعني لاحظنا
لبعض الجثث على الشارع بس مش واضح ملامحها
لكن
جثه هيك مش باينه تعاليمها واغلبها محروقه
يعني للاسف بس يعني اوضاع قصف صعب يعني عن
جد ما ما حصل في احنا شفنا هذا الحكي في
الخرطوم او في السودان مع عهدنا عليها هذا
الحكي يعني بس الوضع كثير كان صعب والحمد
لله رب العالمين لو بدك توصف الاوضاع من
حيث الامان الان في الخرطوم بصراحه كيف
توصفها فيه لو فيها امان ما جينا
يعني كنا سبنا سياراتنا مصارينا
بزنس تبعنا شغلنا كلنا طلعنا بواعينا بس
هناك كيف الوضع هناك توصل لنا طول ما دام
وصلنا بلدنا الحمد لله احنا بنعمل بننسى
التعب بننسى كل شيء الوضع بصراحه صعب في
البلد تحكي لنا عنه من اي ناحيه كيف القصف
كنت قريب من القصف من القتل احنا بالنسبه
لنا كان القصف جنبنا يعني كويس حتى شغلنا
الضرر وصار في نهب وصار في سرقه الشوارع
الجثث يعني شفت بعينك فعلا
تقعد ثلاث اربع ايام ما شالوها شوف نسبه
الجثث مش كبيره بس موجوده وبعدين اللي
بيصير انه صار في عمليه النهب والسرقه صار
في استغلال للوضع اللي بصير يعني صح انه
في قصف وصار فيه يعني بس في نهب للبيوت
للصيدليات قديش قديش نسبه الامان اذا بدنا
نحكي نشوف احنا بالنسبه لنا ماشيين من اول
امبارح عشان نوصل هون ما بعرف عنده خرطوم
برا الى احلى يعني كانت جايتنا خطوره
وقعدتنا هنا خطوره بس جيتنا اامن من
قعدتنا يعني ممكن انت تكون قاعد تجيك
قذيفه على البيت تقصفك وصارت فعلا وصارت
كثير صارت مع في ناس اردنيين هون مصالحهم
شغلهم تضرر بشكل كبير الحمد لله فش اصابات
في الجاليه الاردنيه احنا يعني
الحمد لله ما في اي اصابات والامور الحمد
لله وسفرتنا الله يجزيها الخير كانت
متابعه معنا اول باول عظيم والحمد اول شيء
الحمد لله على سلامتكم ايش شعورك لما اول
ما نزلت الطياره في عمان كيف بصراحه طبعا
شعور بالامان يعني احنا قلنا اسبوع انا
طلعت على شغلي يوم السبت اللي فات لما
بدات الاحداث وبديت اشتغل ما شفت الا
هالرصاص وهالضرب وهالناس وهالعالم احنا
اسبوع لثمانيه ايام خوف وقعد وقاعدين
بالبيت ومش قادرين نتحرك وفي عنا وفي يعني
انا في تحت يعني معي عندي 50 شخص في الشغل
جوازاتهم واغراضهم معي انا اللي قدامك
بالخزنه لحد الان ما قدرت اخذه في تسهيل
طبعا الخارجيه لجوازاتكم بالدخول هلا بكل
شيء الله يجزيهم الخير والاردن ما بنسوا
اولاده يعني اكيد اكيد الحمد لله على
السلامه الحمد لله على السلامه الخوف راح
نتمنى للسودان الشقيق طبعا انه تكون
امورهم كلها على خير ما يرام شكرا جزيلا
طاهر طبعا هنالك قصص وحكايه كثيره نحاول
ان يعني نستمع اليها نعم الحمد لله على
السلامه الحمد لله على السلامه
من السودان من الخرطوم من الخرطوم نعم نعم
كيف الاوضاع بدنا نسمع انتم شهاداتكم بعرف
متعبين مرهقين ولكن ايش اللي شفتوه اتمنى
الخير لاخواننا في الخرطوم يعني والوضع
كارثي وماساوي وفي نقص في مواد الغذائيه
والنقص في الوسائل النقل والكهرباء
ونتمنى لهم الخير اكثر من هيك ما بنقدر
نقول كنت قريب من مناطق القصف والقتال نعم
نعم في العاصمه نعم
ايش اللي قاعد بيصير على الارض الجثث اللي
موجوده على الارض
من من جراء القصف في المنازل ما خرجنا
بتعليمات السفاره الاردنيه كانت توجيهات
هناك بعدم الخروج من المنازل وخلينا في
المنازل يعني وما طلعنا من البيوت بس صوت
القذائب والضرب
اشتباكات باسلحه ثقيله يعني
اشي كبير بنتمنى الخير لاهلنا في السودان
قلت ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ربنا بمن
عليهم بالخير والبركه وبمن عليهم بالامن
والسلام الرحله البريه من الخرطوم الى
بورسودان كانت امنه والله الحمد لله رب
العالمين
مخلفات الحرب يعني
اليات وكذا كانت موجوده اما غير ما شفناها
يعني حروب مباشره قدامنا ما شفنا نتمنى
لهم الخير ان شاء الله
الان لما وصلت يعني مطار عمان ايش شعورك
قديش راح الخوف طبعا الحمد مش لما شفت
القوات الاردنيه والقوات المسلحه نفسيا
ارتحت انه خلاص انا بين ايدي امينه ان شاء
الله يا رب وربنا يعطيهم العافيه وما
قصروا وشكرا شكرا شكرا شكرا طاهر هذه
شهادات اشخاص يعني انت تستمع ربما طبعا هم
في حاله من التعب والارباك ربما عمار
ميسون معك عذرا ميسون معك الان عمار انا
الميسون عذرا نحن ما زلنا نتابع معك وصول
ان نستمع نعم يعني نحن ايضا نريد منك اننا
نحاول فقط ان نستمع الى اكبر الحمد لله
على السلامه
من وين من اي مدينه جئت من الخرطوم برضه
كنت قريب من المناطق الاشتباكات المعارك
بعرف انت مرهق وتعبان يعطيك العافيه ولكن
انتم بتحملوا شهاده حيه حقيقيه شفتوها
هناك اشرح لنا ايش شفت ايش اللي بيصير
هناك
كان القصف من كل محل والضرب من كل محل
الواحد كان في محل يعني بالمره
طلع من البيوت صعبه
المشتريات المواد التموينيه كلها الاشياء
هاي صعبه كانت الكهرباء مي ما كان في
موجود
[موسيقى]
فيها تعب بس الحمد لله
الان التعب والخوف ان شاء الله بيروح انت
في بوطنك يعني وصلت امن الحمد لله على
السلامه ولكن انا لو بدي توصف لي الوضع من
حيث الامان في السودان ايش بتلخصوا كيف
بتلخصوا لا حاليا ما في امان بالمره حاليا
في الوقت الحالي وفي الوقت
صعب جدا هنا الحمد لله على السلامه انا
بدي احاول اتحدث للاخوات هنا اذا تحدثوا
الينا الحمد لله على السلامه حضرتك
اردني نعم الحمد لله من وين اي مدينه جئت
انا من الخرطوم من الخرطوم نعم من الخرطوم
مرهقين جميعا انا اعرف ذلك ولكن نسمع
واحنا طبعا في السفر والحمد لله تعدينا
طبعا للمرحله الاولى كانت الخطره في
الطريق اي مرحله من الخرطوم الى الخرطوم
الى منطقه مدني منطقه مدني طبعا تبعد 180
كيلو متر يعني والحمد لله وصلنا الى ارض
الوطن بكل الامان بس انا بدي اسمع شهادتك
في التفاصيل كيف كانت الطريق من من
الخرطوم الى مدني لانه كان في اشتباكات
الدعم السريع كان فيها الايام الماضيه
وبعدين كيف لحين وصلتوا الى بورسودان توصف
لنا الموضوع طبعا الطريق شاقه ومتعبه جدا
لكن كان مثل ما اسلفت انه مرحله الخطره
كانت من الخرطوم الى مدني بعد مدني تقريبا
وانت ذاهب الى منطقه ولايه القضارف لغايه
بعد منطق ولايه الكسلا كانت الامور لا
فعلا بعد ما خرجنا من ولايه القضاء حوالي
نصف ساعه كان هناك في قصه بالطائرات يبدو
انه كان في بعد هيك
اي نعم وبلغنا انه الحمد لله انه تم انه
وصولكم الى كسله او بنصف الطريق
امنه قبل ان يتم القصف من قبل الجيش
السوداني على الدعم السليم طيب انت حضرتك
كنت في الخرطوم كنت قريب من اماكن
الاشتباكات والقصف وشفت كان ايش شفت ايش
مشاهد ايش ايش القصف نسمعه يوميا منذ صباح
الباكر ذوي اطلاق النار وكذلك المدفعيه
وكان يعني بشكل وتيره دائما يعني مستمر
مستمره وازعاج شديد لهذا الموضوع يعني
بصراحه يعني هو يعني المنطقه فيها كان
قريبه على المطار والقياده يعني وكان
الوضع فعلا فيما
يتعلق على الدواء الغذاء الماء الكهرباء
ايضا الجثث المتواجده في الشوارع ايش
شهاداتك انت كشخص جئت من هناك ايش شفت من
هذا كله من هذا الشيء ما شفت انا الجثث
لكن
اسمعنا هذا الشيء لكن بالنسبه
للمستشفيات فعلا الامور معدومه من ناحيه
الطبيه
وحتى لو بتحتاج الدواء الصيدليات مغلقه ما
بتقدر يعني بنفس الوقت كنا نخرج من اجل
نحصل على المؤن او نحصل على
الطعام كنا بحذر شديد خاصه بالنهار وبعد
المغرب كان الخروج يكون في خطوره جدا على
الشخص يعني ما يقدر يخرج نهائي يعني لانه
بيكون في
عالي جدا حقيقه في هذا الموضوع انا انا
اهنيك اولا بالسلامه ونشكر الله ولكن ولكن
سريعا باختصار اذا بدك توصف الوضع من حيث
الامان في السودان كيف توصفه للناس
عم بيزداد سوء لحد اللحظه هاي ولا يوجد
الامان اللي نحكي فيه انه حد يقدر يؤمن
على نفسه حقيقه الموضوع ودعونا اول شيء
نشكر الله عز وجل على وصولنا بامان لارض
الوطن وبنشكر جلاله الملك عبد الله الثاني
ابن الحسين المعظم على متابعته الحثيثه
حقيقه على وتشكيل خليه الازمه من ضمن
اندلاع الحرب ومتابعه على تواصل معكم من
اللحظه الاولى وعنا احنا تطبيق على
الجاليه الاردنيه ومتابعه لكل الجاليه
الاردنيه والطلاب في هذا الموضوع وكذلك
بمتابعه من وزاره الخارجيه والممثله كذلك
الشكر لسفيرنا سائد الردايده ومحمد
الطراونه له القدس وكافه الاخوان واللي هو
رئيس الجاليه كذلك واحنا ايضا نشكرهم
جميعا الحمد لله
يعني فعلا بدون ذكر اسماء كذلك والله ما
قصروا لغايه ما وصلنا الى هنا ولم يالوا
اي جهد في هذا الموضوع ان شاء الله الحمد
لله
انا بس بحاول اسمع شهادات اخرى من الاخوان
الحمد لله على سلامتك حضرتك اردني من اي
مدينه احنا من
الخرطوم نعم انا طبعا الحمد لله بفضل الله
كنت المشرف على عمليه الاجلاء احنا شركه
البهاوس كنا المخدم في عمليه الاجلاء
المواطنين الاردنيين من الخرطوم الى
بورسودان طيب عدد الباصات كانت سبع باصات
ممتاز بدي تحكي لي كانسان انت كنت عايش
هناك بصرف النظر عن اي شيء ايش اللي شفته
انتم يعني لديكم مشاهدات حيه مما يحدث
هناك
راينا الحرب راينا الصواريخ راينا الناس
الذي تموتون راينا الجثث كثيره في الشوارع
لم يتم الاحياء كانت الجثه هذه جميعها في
الخرطوم تحديدا في شارع المطار في شارع
عبيد ختم في شارع الستين هذه ابرز اسماء
الشوارع التي كانت يوجد فيها احداث معارك
حقيقيه الرصاص كان ياتي من فوق رؤوسنا
دائما
كنا كثيرا يعني لا نستطيع ان نرجع الى
بيوتنا نضطر الى ان نجلس عند اخرين من اجل
ان نحافظ هناك طيب الطريق من من الخرطوم
الى بورسودان بمرورا بمدني كيف كانت خطيره
خطيره جدا واجهتنا كثير من المصاعب
لدرجه ان كثير من الاليات
ما بين الدعم السريع واليات الجيش كانت
موجوده على الطرقات
مشاهد مرعبه جدا لا يستطيع تخيلها احد
ربما يعني انا
اثقل في عمليات سلب وعمليات ناب كانت تحدث
بجوز ما بعرف اذا تقدر تجاوبني بس من
الجهه التي كانت تفعل ذلك انت الان خارج
السودان وليس نحن لا نعرف لانهم في
النهايه هم كلهم يلبسون زي عسكري
لا نستطيع
نعم لكن نحن بصفتنا كنا نعرف ان هذا دعم
سريع او هذا جيش لكن لم نكن نحسم ان هذا
دعم سريع او جيش ممتاز انا بدي بدي اهنيك
على سلامتك انت وكل الاردنيين ونتمنى طبعا
انه العافيه وانه الامور في السودان تكون
على خير ما يرام الحمد لله على السلامه
سيدي حضرتك اردني اهلا وسهلا من اي مدينه
جئت جئت من الخرطوم من الغضارف
زمان انت عايش في الخرطوم لا انا سايق
براد تمام يعني انت كنت صدفه هناك مثلا في
عمل كنت في سائق براد انقل بضائع من سوريا
او الاردن على السودان يعني انت ذهبت في
عمل وعلقت هناك بسبب الاحداث طيب ايش شفت
ايش شهادتك على اللي شفته هناك من معارك
شفت شيء من هاي المعارك
شفت قصف عشوائي
وسلب وسرقات نعم حتى موثق عندي على
التلفون عندك فيديوهات واحد
طيب فعلا شوف الجثثها في الطرقات
كنت في حاله رعب انت يبدو انا حاسك زي
المظلوم او يعني اول مره واحد يشوف حرب
هيك يعني الواقع بنشوف على التلفزيون
على شاشات القنوات بس اول مره يعني نشوف
يعني
اخواننا سالتهم عن نسبه الامان في السودان
اليوم قالوا لي غير امنه تماما هذا يؤسفنا
ولكن يعني انت ايش رايك بهذا غير امنه حتى
هم يعني بالوقت الحالي صاروا الطريق بعيده
صار يحفروا الطريق عشان السيارات تهدي
ويسلبوها يعني اشخاص يسلب السيارات على
الطريق من خرطوم الى بورسودان بيحفر
الشارع اعملوا حفر كبيره عشان السياره
اجباري توقف وقف تام وانهالوا عليها
بالسلب مثلا
هذا رايتموه ولا سمعت عنه لا صارت
صارت قدامنا قدامنا يعني
أنا بعذرك طبعا على انك مرهق ومتعب وانا
اسف اني غلبتك الحمد لله على السلامه يعني
نحن سعداء ورجوعك الى الاردن الحمد لله
على السلامه ميسون نعم الشهادات كثيره
تحياتي الحمد لله على السلامه حضرتك
اردنيه
مش حابه تحكي المهم انه الحمد لله على
السلامه انك بخير وهاي طفلتك الحمد لله
على سلامتكم الحمد لله على السلامه سيدي
حضرتك سوداني
اهلا وسهلا
طيب انا بعرف انكم جميعا مرهقين ولكن احنا
مضطرين نسمع شهاداتكم لانه الفرصه ان
نلتقيكم الان ايش ايش احكي لنا شو اللي
شفتوه من هناك من القصف المعارك ايش اللي
قاعد بيصير لا المعرقة كنا قاعدين جوا
بيوتنا يعني
بالمعارك ولا بس لكن شاهد تسمعوا قصفوا
اشتباكات
بس
طريق من الطريق من الخرطوم الى بورت سودان
كيف كانت
كويس يعني الحمد لله
معروفين يعني الاردن معروف في خدمته
اقصد اقصد انه الطريق امن ولا كان في بعض
مشاكل
يعني 30 40
كيلو في المحله قريب ومحلل اي بس لكن بعد
ما طلعنا من هناك بشويه بس قالوا لنا
دخلنا اه يعني انتم واجهتوا خطوره بعد 30
او 40 كيلو من الخرطوم باتجاه مدني
وباتجاه بورسودان صحيح
ما كان في داري بس الدرب الاول اللي كان
ابتداوا العصارات موجوده في الطريق يعني
اثار القصف الحمد لله على السلامه وان شاء
الله نتمنى لسودان ان يعود الامور مستتبه
فيه وبامان ان شاء الله قريبا الحمد لله
على السلامه حبيبي انت الحمد لله على
سلامتك من وين جيت من اي مدينه جيت من
الخرطوم انت والعائله انا معي اهلي مقيمين
هناك مقيمين ايوه كنتوا قريبين من مكان
القصف ايش شفتوا هناك احكيلنا بالمطار وكل
يوم والله في رصاص ضرب رصاص قوي كثير
قنابل
والله هي اول ما بلشت اصلا كنا نسافر يوم
احد فصارت الحرب
والله بس كان يعني تطلع طيارات جنب بيتنا
بيجوا قنابل ودخلت ثلاث رصاصات على البيت
عبيتكم اه الحمد لله بس طلع ما في الحمد
لله الحمد لله الحمد لله يعني
انت قريب من منطقه المطار ايوه كنا قريبه
من منطقه المطار لما طلعتوا من البيت
وخليتوه كيف كيف طلعتوا من البيت باتجاه
لما طلعنا من البيت قال ان الجيش سيطر على
المطار
وعملوا هدنه بس ما التزموا فيها واحنا
والله قدرنا نطلع صاحب يعني انت صاحب ابوي
معاه سياره كويسه
وتقدرنا نطلع ايش شفتوا على الطريق ايش
اسمك حضرتك اسمي محمد محمد ايش شفته على
الطريق والله كان في
ارتكازات للدعم السريع
كانوا واقفين بالشارع يعني وصار يهددوا
فيه طلقتين بالهواء وبس ما لما شاف انه
السفر الاردنيه ما حكوا اشي بخوفوا يعني
طيب شفتوا اثار قصف معارك وانتم ماشيين
شفتوا جثث مثلا جثث لا انا ما شفت بس شفت
في عماره والله في شارع منطقه شارع اسمه
شارع الستين في عماره وقعت عليها قذيفه
مضبوط صح فينا شفناها والله شفناها بعنايه
وفي فيديو مصور بس
ممنوع انه نعرض طيب انت بصراحه بجوز كان
في خوف كبير وانت هناك هلا كيف حاسس لا
هسا الحمد لله طمنت لما شفت جيش الله
يحفظهم ما شاء الله
اطمن انت يعني
اطمنت ايوه دخلت الحمد لله على السلامه
الله يحفظ لك اهلك وان شاء الله نتمنى
للسودان ان تعود اليه وهو امن ان شاء الله
ميسون يعني احنا هذه شهادات
مختلفه ومتفرقه الاشخاص تجربه تجربه صعبه
جدا
نعم تجربه صعبه جدا ولكن اريد منك
عمار ان تعطينا هل هناك من ارقام لاشخاص
غير اردنيين ايضا كانوا علامه هذه
الطائرات التي وصلت الى الاردن
صحيح هذه الطائرات حملت 343 شخص 300 منهم
اردنيين من اصل 450 اردنيا هنالك 150
اردنيا بقوا في السودان طلبوا من الخارجيه
ان يبقوا هناك بناء يعني وتحملوا مسؤوليه
قرارهم وابلغ السلطات الاردنيه بانهم
يرغبون في البقاء هناك وبالتالي عاد 300
من الاردنيين هنالك 43 شخص من جنسيات
مختلفه من العراق الجنسيه العراقيه من
الجنسيه الفلسطينيه من الجنسيه السوريه
ومن الجنسيه الالمانيه قامت القوات
المسلحه الاردنيه سلاح الجو الملكي
باجلائهم مع المواطنين الاردنيين من مطار
بورتشودان بنفس الطريقه تم نقلهم من المدن
السودانيه ميسون الى بورت سودان برا وبعد
ذلك تم تامينهم بهذه الطائرات التي وصلت
للتو
ووصلوا الى العاصمه عمان هذه الصور التي
تشاهدين هذا الازدحام هو طبعا لختم جوازات
السفر لانه هنالك
اجراءات قانونيه لابد لابد ان تتم بحيث
يعني يختم كل مسافر جواز سفره لدخول
الاردن الحمد لله على السلامه من انت
اردني حضرتك من اي مدينه جيتوا من الخرطوم
من الخرطوم احنا بنسمع شهادات اللي شفتوه
هناك بنعرف منكم تعبانين ولكن بحاول استغل
كل شخص اسمع ايش اللي صار احكوا لنا لانه
الناس ما سمع بدنا ايش لا احكي لنا
لا حتى المعارك ايش اللي شفتوه هناك كيف
ايش القصف وين كنت موجود في نص الخرطوم
ومعظم الجاليه الاردنيه في نص الخرطوم
والقصف كان او يعني الاشتباكات كانت
عشوائيه ما فيش مناطق محدده عندهم غيرها
بمعظم المناطق كان في اشتباكات بعض
المناطق اهدا شويه من مناطق ثانيه لكن ما
بتضمن القصف العشوائي ولا بتضمن المدافع
او القنابل العشوائيه اللي كانت
والكل كان متعرض لخطوره في اقامته في
الخرطوم
شفت في عينك مشاهد الجثث في الشوارع ولا
انت من الناس اللي سمعت وين ما شفت والله
انا سمعت ما شفت بس احنا مثلا في عمارتنا
صدف انه نزل اكم من رصاصه على البنايه انا
البنايه على الحيط او لقينا باب المدخل
المدخل العماره كان في برضو رصاص
وشفنا بعيننا في بعض المناطق اللي هي مثلا
في الاحياء اللي جنبنا قذائف سقطت على
عمارات بيوت تدمرت اشياء زي هيك شفنا بعين
ربما يعني انا اثقل عليك فيه انه منفك
بتعتقد انت يتحمل مسؤوليه العمليات اللي
بتحدث من النهب من القتل العشوائي من
القاء القذائف من الطرفين اذا كنت تود ان
يعني كمقيم هناك يكون لك رايي بهذا الامر
تحميل المسؤوليه مش مش هو المهم المهم انه
في حالات زي حاله الحرب بيصير في انفلات
امنيه
فعلا
وفي بعض العصابات هي موجوده اصلا في
الخرطوم من قبل
هذه بتنشط في حاله عدم وجود بس ايش عملت
يعني اللي سمعناه انه كتير مناطق او كثير
اللي هي المناطق اللي في اطراف الخرطوم
الناس عمالهم بيتعرضوا للنهب انا واحد من
الناس عندي معارف كتير في الخرطوم سواء
اردنيين او سودانيين بحكم انه صار لي 20
سنه في الخرطوم 20 سنه نعم فاللي بنسمعه
سواء من السودانيين او من الاردنيين او من
الجاليات الاخرى كان في في مواقف كثيره
ناس تعرضوا لسلب ونهب في الشارع وناس
تعرضوا لسلب في بيوتهم مين الجهه اللي
كانت تسلبهم في عصابه اسمها نيجرز مش يعني
قوات مسلحه دعم سريع او قوات الدعم السريع
انه في في بعض المناطق نهب من الناس وفي
الشوارع كان في لهم محلات او يعني نقاط هم
المسؤولين عن التفتيش فيها فكانوا بينهبوا
من المواطنين اللي بيمرقوا من هذه النقاط
سريعا الطريق اللي بين الخرطوم لبورسودان
امن ولا غير امن اول تقريبا 25 كيلو هي
كانت الخطوره فيها واحنا للعلم يوم الجمعه
اول يوم العيد تجمعنا وكان المفروض ننطلق
في عمليه الاجلاء من من بيت رئيس الجاليه
وما تمكنا لانه الطريق اللي بدنا ناخذها
حصل فيها اشتباكات بالمدافع الثقيله
وبالاسلحه فصار تاجيل صار تاجيل لليوم
الثاني بعد ما انتظرنا حوالي سبع ساعات
وصار تاجيل لليوم الثاني اليوم الثاني
ربنا ييسرها الامور وانطلقنا التنسيق بين
السفاره
والجيش من جهه وبين السفاره والدعم السريع
من جهه ثانيه وكان اول 25 كيلو لغايه ما
طلعنا من الخرطوم تماما من ولايه الخرطوم
كامله كان فيها خطوط
على الجيش عن الدعم السريع طيب على طول
الطريق من يسيطر الجيش ولا الدعم السريع
الدعم السريع شفناه في اول نقطه واحنا
طالعين من الخرطوم اللي هي على بعد حوالي
عشره 15 كيلو وبعد اتجاه مدني باتجاه مدني
نعم مدني هلا بعدها كان في برضه في مدينه
اسمها زياد وقريه اسمها المسعوديه هي شركه
جياد
هي عباره عن مدين
كان فيها اشتباكات في اليوم اللي احنا كان
المفروض نطلع فيه وتاجل كان في اشتباكات
ثقيله واضح اثار المعركه فيها وبعد ذلك
الجيش يسيطر بعد ذلك كل الجيش
عن 600 كيلو تقريبا 670
المسافه اللي قطعناها من مدني من مدني فقط
حوالي 1000 كيلو لبورسود بعد مدني الجيش
يسيطر حتى بورسودان قبل شكرا الحمد لله
على السلامه غايه في الاهميه لانه احنا
بنحب نسمع من ناس فعلا شافوا بعينهم اكيد
يعني اول اشي بهني كل اخواننا الجاليه
الاردنيه بسلامتهم بشكر كل من ساهم بوصلنا
للاردن لانه يعني كنا في معاناه
[موسيقى]
اتمنى من الكل يدعي للشعب السوداني الطيب
الكريم المضياف اللي حتى في اسوا الظروف
اول نقطه وقفنا فيها
السواق الباص نزل عشان يعني بيته في
الطريق نزل على قريه
من القرى النائيه
بس هو مجرد ما نزل لقينا نسوان الحاره
تقريبا عشر 15 مره طالعين معهم حفاضات
المياه عشان نشربوا الغذاء والماء
ويعتذروا فوق هاد بعتذروا انه المي مش
بارده لانه صار لنا اربعه ايام بدون
كهرباء نتمنى لهم ان شاء الله العوده
قريبا ان يعود السودان جميل كما كان وان
يكون مستتب امن مستتب ام ميسون انا حاولت
ان احصل على يعني اكبر عدد من هذه
الشهادات من الاخوان
طبعا كافيه اخرى ولكن
يعني الشهادات اللي سمعناها كانت كافيه
وافيه عن الاوضاع السيئه جدا في السودان
اريد ان اسال عمار بعض الاشخاص الذين
قابلتهم وقال لك انه لم يكن لديه جواز سفر
بهذه الحالات كيف تم التعامل مع هؤلاء
الاشخاص
الخارجيه الاردنيه قامت بالتاكد طبعا من
هويتهم واعطتهم وثيقه للسفر بموجب هذه
الوثيقه الان يدخل الاردني ويختم هذه
الوثيقه وبعد عادي وببساطه يتوجه الى
منزله وبامكانه ان يستخرج جواز سفر جديد
وبالتالي كل هذه الصعوبات بددتها يعني
وزاره الخارجيه في الحقيقه مما سمعت انا
من الناس ومما شهدته من خلال الايام انه
كانت وزاره الخارجيه على متابعه حديثه مع
الاردنيون هناك وكان هنالك ايضا تاني كبير
ميسون في وصول هذه الطائرات تاجل وصولها
اكثر من مره لانه كان هنالك احتياطات
امنيه كبيره كان هنالك معلومات دقيقه لم
تفصح عنها الخارجيه يعني عن مثلا
عدد الطائرات اليوم فقط اعلنت انها اربع
طائرات فبالتالي كانت هنالك جهود كبيره
جدا في سبيل ان تصل هذه الاعداد من
الاردنيين وغير الاردنيين الذين تم
اجلائهم من السودان الى عمان امنين والحمد
لله يعني هم بخير جميعا ولم والمهم ايضا
ميسون انه لم يسجل حتى هذه اللحظه الحمد
لله وان شاء الله لا يسجل اي اصابه في
صفوف الجاليه الاردنيه وطبعا اذكر ميسون
بانه هنالك 150 شخصا اردنيا بقوا هناك في
السودان بناء على رغبتهم هم طلبوا البقاء
في السودان ولم يعودوا معه طائرات سلاح
الجو الملكي نعم على كل حال عمار دائما
سنكون معك اذا بحال اصبح لديك ايضا اشخاص
قادرين انه يعطوا شهاداتهم نعود اليك حال
اي ورود ورود اي جديد معك او اي شهادات
جديده شكرا لك عمار حتى الان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات